how many tourists are too many a hundred
snorkelers on the water's surface and a
whale shark down below the world's
biggest fish comes to the flat coral
reef to eat it's one of the Maldives
main tourist attractions every year a
million vacationers come here in search
of paradise coral reefs are among the
earth's most species-rich ecosystems and
among the most fragile marine biologist
Ameer Abdullah works for the
International Union for the Conservation
of Nature he wants to protect the reef
from things like climate change sewage
overfishing and tourists walking on the
reef the reefs arch enemy is mad as a
nation proverb that says in tourism is
tourism's like a fire you can cook your
dinner with it or it can burn your house
down so I think it's a double-edged
sword you know tourism can be very
positive or it could be very negative
the hotel's working with the iucn
project house reef want tourism that
benefits the reef the german manager of
ratty beach hotel is a trailblazer
denyse schmidt tender team want to guard
and protect the islands reef in IUCN
marine biologists being trained by
Abdullah will help in a setting is first
of all of course we're acting in our own
interest the reef the island is a
privilege for us and we naturally have
to see that we protect it the tourists
come to dive but if there's nothing here
any more than they won't come off kind
of it for the next three years marine
biologist baba cacao will monitor the
condition of the reef just off the
island and she'll provide information on
the fragile coral too interested
tourists like vanna takes long elegant
has a long time diver I've become more
careful in recent years but every new
bit of information increases awareness
that as a diver you have to be more
careful with the environment good where
are the unique coral species and where
is the reef endangered grazie and
abdullah are creating maps and
management plans they hope the project
will make the reef less susceptible the
coral reefs are exactly like human
beings in many ways if they are healthy
and they're not stressed by local
impacts and they'll be able to resist
the impacts of climate change
and if our programs are successful coral
reefs will then have the best potential
to recover from these impacts